okay so if Gerard Butler's character was
not a Secret Service agent was actually
a New York cop and played by Bruce
Willis this would have been the perfect
die hard five Olympus has fallen as
directed by Antoine Fuqua who brought us
training day this movie stars Gerard
Butler Aaron Eckhart Morgan Freeman
Robert Forester Ashley Judd and Dylan
McDermott amongst many others this movie
is about a Secret Service agent played
by Butler and he has an experience with
the president and his wife that goes
wrong and it really affects him
emotionally and he has to kind of step
away from it from a while and all of a
sudden when terrorists attack the White
House and take the president hostage
he's the one guy left in the White House
on this day who has the skills and the
ability to save the president and try to
save the nation from these terrorists
that are invading now looking from that
you can say well that's definitely die
hard in the White House and you would be
right and that is exactly why I had so
much fun with this movie so you going
into this movie I saw the previews and
it just looked like a 90s action movie
like straight out of 1997 or something
like Broken Arrow or face off or Conair
or the rock you know these action movies
they don't make anymore it was really
fun just completely full-blooded action
films that just for 100% adrenaline with
a fun plot but had a lot of political
weight to it as well and kind of a
patriotic vibe like Air Force one they
used to make really fun action movies
like that in the 90s that were cheesy
that were filled with one-liners over a
lot of fun and that you could watch and
enjoy and the crowd could be pleased
this movie is like Air Force one deep
impact and die hard all combined into
one film and it works very well on that
level if you go into this movie and you
want to have a good time with it this is
just a 100 percent fun
popcorn film you can't overanalyze this
movie this movie isn't meant to be that
way this is just an extremely fun action
adventure that had some really good
performances in it and it's definitely
one of Gerard Butler's better films
Morgan Freeman is in this film as the
Acting President when Aaron Eckhart is
under hostage and as usual Morgan
Freeman is just awesome he has some clap
inducing lines in the film where you
just want to go that is Morgan Freeman
mmm there are certain movies that are
made that try to get that consistent
applause out of you where it wants you
to feel all patriotic some movies fail
at that horribly like battleship that
was a movie that kept trying to get the
audience to applaud for America and for
the soldiers and for the troops and
everything and it was just really forced
and annoying Olympus has fallen actually
has a fun leading character and yes you
can tell it steals a lot from the whole
diehard plot and there will be critics
that just say cuz copies of die hard I
found it to be really enjoyable though
and I found Gerard Butler really
entertaining and good in this film he
was good with the action scenes he was
fun as a character and as the main hero
even though there were definite
comparisons to be made with John McClane
I still found myself really enjoying him
in this film
Aaron Eckhart was very good as the
president and the main villain of the
film whose name I don't remember he was
the villain and die another day although
a lot of his lines seemed a little audio
dub he was convincing as a villain
because this film was actually well
directed even though it might have been
just a tad too shaky for my taste a few
times in the movie I really thought this
movie was directed well and it added to
the villains performance the way the
director assembled this movie I really
had fun with it and it's just one of
those movies that made me feel like I
was in like 1997 watching one of those
kind of cheesy fun action films just
relishes in what it is this movie
completely recognizes that and it has a
lot of fun with it
one thing is to be said though this
movie is actually surprisingly violent
the action does not pull any punches
at all and some people may actually be
offended by some of the things that are
in this movie but this honestly was the
movie that I wanted diehard 5 to be like
if they would have just replaced that
character with John McClane die hard 5
would have been awesome on its own right
Olympus has fallen has good performances
it's a lot of fun it's a cheesy popcorn
movie that's just a good time so
recognize that when you go in I'm gonna
give Olympus has fallen a b-plus if you
see the movie this weekend I'd love to
know what you think or what your
thoughts are on the movie from the
trailer or which is what you think about
the film thanks a lot always for
watching guys and if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck my
next
[Music]